خلال الايام الماضيه انتشر على مواقع
التواصل الاجتماعي فيديو واثقوا اندلاع عن
ايران في حافله مدرسيه بينما كانت تسير في
احد شوارع مدينه بجنوب فرنسا فيما تمكن
السائق وجميع الاطفال العشره الذين كانوا
علمتنها من مغادرتها في الوقت المناسب ولم
تسجل اي اصابات في الحادثه
في مشهد النادر وثق سعوديون مقطع فيديو
متداول على مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
للحظات الاولى لتساقط الثلوج على جبل
اللوز في نيوم وظهر المقطع وسقوط ثلوجا
غزيره على الجبل وسط وجودي عدد من الاشخاص
الذين كانوا يستمتعون بهذه الظاهره الجويه
[موسيقى]
مطبخ اثار التعاطفا واسعا على مواقع
التواصل الاجتماعي بلونه الاصفر المميز في
دينيبر الاوكرانيه تحول من مكان قضت فيه
هذه العائله لحظات السعيده الى ذكريات
مؤلمه بعد ان دمر المبنى بالكامل بعدما ان
دمر المبنى بالكامل جراءه قصف طلبه الا ان
المطبخ بالوانه الفريضه ظل بارزا وسط
الحطب نشاهد
[موسيقى]
كاسات مقاطع ان العمره مجرد رقم خاضت
المصريه زبيده سعيده اختباري محو الاميه
وتحلم بالنجاح وهي تبلغ من العمر 87 عاما
زبيده اثرت على تعليم ابنائها الثمانيه
وشقيقاتها بعد وفاه والدها قالت حلم قالت
حلم حياتي كان استكمالي تعليمهم فعلت كل
ما بوسعي حتى يكونوا ناجحين ومتفوقين
والان حماده
بالحصول على شهاده التعليميه في التعليم
نجاح وعزل النفس قبل اي شيء اخر
كان هذا كل شيء لليوم الى اللقاء